[Music]
[Applause]
Andy Staples covers college football for
on three Sports our good buddy back with
us let's get the uh conference moves
potential conference moves realignment
ACC out of the way first what is the
latest as we head into week one of the
season
well the ACC was supposed to have a
conference call on Monday among its
presidents to decide well further
discuss potentially adding Stanford
Callan SMU and that has been postponed
because of what happened in Chapel Hill
and so they have not rescheduled that
yet we're still waiting this still makes
no sense to me why they would add these
guys from a practical sense from a I get
the finances of it SMU wants to take no
money Stanford and Cal are given a heavy
discount so you can use some of that
money to to make Florida State and
Clemson happy I guess but they're still
not going to be happy because they still
won't make as much as SEC or Big Ten
schools so they're still probably going
to try to leave so it doesn't make much
sense to me other than your backfilling
in case they do leave and you're making
sure that ESPN can't cut what they pay
you that's that's all I can think to
that makes it make sense but if Cowan
Stanford and SMU don't join the ACC
then what
then I I still think that if Callan
Stanford don't wind up in the ACC there
there's a way for Cal Stanford
Washington State and Oregon State to use
all of the you know trademarks branding
of the of the Pac-12 the NCAA tournament
unions which are worth real money that
the Pac-12 is owed and perhaps they
merged with another conference not take
schools from another conference because
then those schools would have to pay
buyouts or or exit fees but merge with
another conference say the Mountain West
and use all the pack brand name I mean
you could you could do that and become
the pac-16 and you'd have a conference
and there you go and you let the the
Mountain West people run it because
they're better at running a conference
than the Pac-12 people are but that's
something you could do or if you wanted
you could just hang as those four teams
for a couple of years you really could
that they they'll let they'll let them
do that because of what's happened and
then figure it out it would be a hell of
a three-game conference schedule but but
can you still get an automatic birth if
you win the Pac-12 like what what
constitutes the Pac-12 the language that
allows you to be an automatic qualifier
that would have to be determined by the
college football playoff by all the
Commissioners that run it now for the
bass basketball tournament you'd need
five you'd have to figure out a way to
add a fifth school to get to get an
automatic bid into the into the
basketball tournament but uh for the for
the football one my guess is they'd be
like we're not giving you an automatic
bid if you only have four teams
how many teams can win the national
title
oh I'd say there's probably about
four or five how many could go to the
national title game well that's that's a
different question because we saw TCU do
it last year so it it kind of depends on
on how you get matched up in that first
semi-final but let's make the list right
now I'd say Georgia I'd say Ohio State
Michigan I actually think Penn State
would be in that group of could go to
the national title game because I think
Penn State could potentially win the Big
Ten this year
um I think Alabama Alabama could
absolutely we will see about the Big 12
teams Texas is talented enough but again
I need to see them win games they're
supposed to win uh if somebody were to
come out of the the Pac-12 12-1 whether
that's USC Washington Oregon then maybe
you could see them doing it but in terms
of just straight up winning it I I think
I'd probably limit it to Georgia
Alabama
Penn State Michigan maybe LSU Ohio State
oh I have yeah I think did I say Ohio
State I think I did yeah they're
certainly talented enough uh the
question is I actually picked Penn State
to make the playoff and Michigan and
Ohio State to miss it so we'll see how
that goes but I'm you know people talked
about old conference realignments
ruining college football Nils ruining
the transfer portals ruining wasn't
college football already ruined from the
standpoint of we I mean it's it's almost
formulaic it feels like it's Alabama
it's Georgia it's Ohio State you throw
Clemson in there sometimes you have an
outlier there but we sort of know what's
going to happen at the end of the season
or at least we know that the schools we
know that Tom Cruise doesn't die in
Mission Impossible but we do know that
his life is in Peril a couple of times
it feels like that's what it is for
college football
it is and that's what I I laugh about
when all the people say well nil is
ruining no it's not the rules they had
before made college football the least
competitive of all the major American
Sports yeah think about think about how
hard it is to be less competitive than
Major League Baseball given Major League
Baseball's rules so you've managed to do
that so the rules before were the
problem like all this nil stuff that
people say is ruining college football
the number one defensive line Prospect
in America just committed to Missouri
because of nil he's not going to
Missouri if there's no nil
if I gave you okay you could have Caleb
Williams or the field for the Heisman or
Georgia versus the field for the
national title
so I take the field for the Heisman in
Georgia for the national title uh and
the only reason I'm taking the feel for
the Heisman is I feel like we as a group
of Voters
just find ways to tear down the repeat
winners or the the potential repeat
winners because Caleb Williams
there's a very good chance he will be
the best player in college football this
year but we we've seen how hard it is to
repeat as a Heisman winner I feel like
if anybody can it's him because he's
just very special you saw it the other
night when he drops the snap and then
and then his instincts are incredible
and
I'm a little worried their defense
hasn't got much better and he's gonna
have to be Superman down the stretch
because they're playing a very tough
schedule at the in the back half of the
season so that one there George I feel
like even though that nobody's
three-peated since 1936 Georgia has a
better roster than everybody and you can
say what you want about them not playing
a tough schedule they were supposed to
play Oklahoma the SEC is like nah we
can't have the return game be a
conference game and this be
non-conference so they're not playing
Oklahoma this year but
they're still just better on both lines
of scrimmage than everybody else and if
there's any universal truth in football
the team with the better big people wins
and Georgia has much better big people
we're talking to Andy Staples covers
college football for on three sports but
why don't other schools replicate what
Alabama and Georgia do LSU's got money
Tennessee's got money I mean you can
look at USC's got money but why is
Georgia now become the new Alabama
because there are so few good big people
that that's the scarcest resource in
college football is ready-made defensive
lineman ready-made offensive lineman
they were all going to Alabama and Ohio
State and Clemson before Georgia started
when as soon as Kirby Smart got to
Georgia he started shearing some of
those off of each of those schools and
you go to you go to the class of 2020
there's there's a group of four players
that considered Georgia and Alabama had
Georgia and Alabama in their finalists
uh one of them's Georgia's current
starting center one of his Darnell
Washington who who was a a tight end
that the the is in the NFL now Jalen
Carter's another one he's with the
Eagles now
if you put those players on Alabama's
roster last year Alabama wins the
national title in the same way Georgia
does but that's what Kirby Smart has
done is managed to find guys and beat
Alabama for those guys LSU Tennessee
they have not been able to beat Alabama
for those guys like Nick Saban still had
the number one recruiting class in the
country in the class of 2023. so but but
how are they beating them Andy
like are they beating him on a field no
that oh okay you're getting them how are
you what are you giving them what's your
enticement is it is it is it just money
well it's not just that it you can you
can say you know everybody did the
duffel bag but it doesn't matter anymore
what they can offer and Ohio State can
offer this too and Clemson's been able
to offer this of late is we make better
draft picks than everybody else okay
look at how many first-round draft picks
George has produced and the thing is you
can actually get somebody at a discount
in the nil world when you can say you
might come out here as a first round
draft pick and here's five guys who just
did
okay
uh is there going to be a breakout team
who's going to be TCU this year that's a
great question you know I've said Penn
State enough Penn State and TCU Penn
State this year TCU last year are
different animals because Penn State has
a bunch of elite NFL Talent olufashion
who's probably the first offensive
tackle off the board uh Abdul Carter and
chop Robinson are very high round NFL
draft picks uh one this year and one
next year so
it's a little bit different but it feels
like they have not been in that mix so
I'm going to put them in there as far as
a TCU that's that's so hard to predict
because that TCU team was so Charmed
eight one score games you know that
Baylor game where they ran the the field
goal team on and it it there's so many
times where it shouldn't have happened
for them and then it did so that's the
one that now I will I will give you one
out of the Big 12 that I think is very
interesting and that's Kansas State they
won The League last year bringing back a
lot four starting offensive linemen are
back Cooper BB is the best interior
offensive line in the country probably
again the teams with the best big people
and that's so if if they were to come
out of Big 12 they could be pretty
interesting great to talk to you again
Andy we'll catch up during the season
thank you thank you Dan Andy Staples
covers college football for on three
Sports